Sauer: Hi.
I'm Fred Sauer.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google.
I'm here today
with Paul Hammant.
Paul's a big
Open Source Advocate
at, uh, Thoughtworks and
Dependency Injection pioneer.
Uh, Thoughtworks is an Agile
preaching consultancy.
And I'd like to ask Paul
some questions today.
Uh, he's had a chance
to test-drive, uh,
our recent, uh, launch
of--of App Engine
and support for the--
the Java language.
I wonder, Paul,
if you could, uh,
share some of your initial
observations with us.
Hammant: Yeah, so I'm--I'm
pretty pleased with App Engine.
It's a very nice environment
to work with.
And, uh, the feature set
that you've shipped with it
is quite compelling too.
Sauer: Uh, what are some of
the--the most important aspects
of what you--what we've just
launched in--in your opinion?
Hammant: Um, in terms
of the experiments
that I've done, I've been
very pleased to find out
that existing Web frameworks
for Java are working quite well
and they're almost unchanged.
Um, and--and there's integration
into Google Accounts.
And that's taken away
a huge problem
that's always part of any
Web application development
in that you don't have to write
a login system.
You don't have to write
a password recovery system.
You don't even have to cater
for, um, hackers
or phishing attacks because
the whole Google capture stuff
is all done very well.
Um, the other--
the main observation--
the other main observation
that I've, um, seen
with this stack is that
their persistence side
is different to other
applications
that Java developers
may have made in the past.
Specifically, this is not
a relational model.
It's gonna require
some thinking from the outside
about how you're gonna
organize your data
inside App Engine.
Sauer: Sure.
Uh, so App Engine, uh, is built
on top of a fairly scalable
distributed datastore.
And I imagine you probably
have some advice
for developers building
very scalable applications
perhaps for the--
for the first time.
What are some recommendations
or tips you might give them?
Hammant: Yeah, so the--
the obvious things
that--to think about
are, um,
the fact that you're being
billed for every CPU second
that you're using and
you're going to try and reduce
that footprint
as much as you can--
shift as many resources
to static as you can.
And then for the--
for any items,
you're going to want to try
and see if you can leverage
memcached for, um, you know,
just shortcutting
the whole request cycle.
Um, and then the other
big piece--
and this is common
with LAMP stack people--
is you're going to want
to use state list
if you can as a--
as a metaphor
for the application
rather than leveraging
the session
for storage of stuff.
Sauer: Sure. State list
gives you scalability.
Hammant: Yes.
Very much so.
Sauer: Um...
Hammant: Well, actually, no.
Google gives you scalability
in this case.
But state list is gonna
give you cheap scalability.
Sauer: Okay.
Uh, so one of the--
the big features of this, uh,
new version of App Engine
is the support
for the Java Runtime.
And I wonder what you think
the--the biggest impact is
of the Java language support
for, uh, some of your customers.
Some of Thoughtworks'
customers.
Hammant: Yeah, um, I thi--
I think there's a huge
cost reduction piece here.
Um, currently,
uh, you know,
it's common for many
Fortune 500 enterprises
to want to build out
their own infrastructure,
not to trust things
out in the clouds.
So they're going to build
that stack.
And they're going to have
support and infrastructure
and electricity and personnel
all assigned to this thing.
And whole work flows around
releases
that are problematic
for them.
Sauer: Sure.
Hammant:
So one of the things
we think or one of the things
I think could happen here
is we might see 90%
of all the costs
for deployment and
infrastructure just disappear.
And that actually,
deployment to production
will be a turnkey event.
Um, quite easy to do
and very, um,
pleasing for the, uh,
customer in question
to experiment with.
So we might see
some of those customers
just commission and experiment
with App Engine
before committing larger sets
of their infrastructure
towards it to see what the
experience was like for them.
Sauer: That makes sense.
What, um, sort of applications
do you think would be
the--the best initial candidates
for--for such a--an attempt?
Hammant: Um, it's gonna be
Web applications.
And Web applications
that are data-centric.
So if you've got a large
data set
that's being read a lot,
then it's suitable
for the App Engine.
But similarly, if you have
an application
that's going to be receiving
data from some other source,
um, App Engine will scale
quite well to receive that data
and then to store it
in BigTable.
But things without doing
the processes perhaps.
Sauer: Until, uh,
we launch support.
Hammant: Yes.
Sauer: Or, uh, schedule tasks.
Which is--which is coming--
forthcoming.
Uh, and maybe, finally,
what do you see
for the--the future
of cloud computing
or what would you like to see
in--in the future
of, uh, App Engine?
Hammant: Okay, so, um,
my wish list would include
mostly additional services,
which is, I think,
the big value add that you guys
have done here.
So stuff around geolocation.
An API that I as a developer
could call
to say
where is my end user?
Um, and how I use that
is my business.
But you might attach
terms and conditions to it
to prevent the loss of the
entire, um, Google IP database
to, um, you know, off-site.
Um, I might also think
that this stack
could be well suited
for the streaming of content
in the future.
I have no knowledge
of what you're actually
going to be putting in it
later.
But to me, um, I see,
uh, CMSs and Wiki systems
being based on this, um,
that might be richer media
and streaming
of their content
directly from the actual
application
rather than handing off a URL
to something like YouTube.
To that end, I think, um,
you could do well
to support DAV as like
a lower level service on--
you know, if Web requests
come in, and they're ordinarily
served by get or by post,
I think it's quite possible here
that you might be supporting
put and delete
in highly sophisticated ways
that would directly pipe data
to, um, it's place in BigTable.
Um, and to support that,
I kinda think that maybe
some of the magic
that Google Code has done
to sit Subversion
on top of BigTable
could be reused by yourselves
to massively enrich
the experience of, um,
users of the App Engine
experience.
Um, and then some other
obvious pieces as well
like integration
into Google Checkout
would provide a payment system
for people--
again built quite cheaply
and scalable,
you know, there's no fixed
fees in here--
um, in such a way that people
wanting to mount,
um, a modest, um,
shopping portal
could choose now
the Google application--
the, um, App Engine stack
and feel fairly pleased
with that choice rather than
traditionally trying
to build out
some PHP solution
and then leveraging
some third party
to handle the payments
and things like that.
It's like a one--
one-stop shop now
for that entire experience.
Sauer: Okay.
Those are great ideas.
Well, thank you
for joining us today.
Hammant: Thank you
for having me.
Sauer: It was a pleasure.